the U.S has confirmed that one of its
soldiers has crossed the border into
North Korea without authorization and
it's thought he's being detained the man
was taking part in a tour on the
demilitarized border separating North
and South Korea according to local media
he was with a group of visitors in the
village of pan monzon when the city
bolted over the brick line marking the
border the U.N has confirmed the
unauthorized Crossing took place and it
says it's working to resolve the
incident
what we do know is that one of our
service members
who was on a tour
willfully and without authorization
crossed the military demarcation line we
believe that he is in the BRK custody
and so we're closely monitoring and
investigating the situation
and working to notify the soldiers next
to Ken
and engaging to address this incident
in terms of my concerns I'm I'm
absolutely foremost concerned about the
welfare of our troop
Mike Khan is joining us live now from
Washington D.C soloid Austin saying that
he's primarily concerned about the
health of the soldiers that crossed the
border but one would imagine this is
pretty embarrassing for the U.S what
more do we know about what happened
well the keyword saying what the
Secretary of Defense said is willfully
and without authorization this appears
to indicate that the soldier went
voluntarily across the demilitary Zone
we understand that he is being held by
North Korean forces at present uh there
are intermediaries that the U.S has used
in the past particularly Sweden to
discuss the matter with the North Korean
authorities however this is potentially
embarrassing as you say the fact that a
serving member of the US could actually
voluntarily cross that DMZ is something
that reflects somewhat badly on the U.S
forces in the particular region so
obviously we heard there from the
Secretary of Defense that they are
trying to get more information about
this uh emphasizing the importance of
looking after their Armed Forces however
at the same time the fact that this
could well have been a voluntary action
really madisa Waters exactly because he
was saying I mean the U.S uses Sweden
normally to negotiate creative at all
with North Korea the UN is saying it is
working to try to resolve the incident
but if the the soldier went voluntarily
over the line and he's now in North
Korea one wonders who can actually talk
to North Korea and what they can say if
they do
indeed yes and also the question arises
about what if the soldier does not want
to return so all of these issues have to
be taken into account now other Pentagon
sources are saying that the soldier in
fact was facing disciplinary charges
which could be a motivation for this
action uh soldiers have walked across
before on rare occasion defected as it
were to the North Korean side and one
particular occasion a soldier wished to
join his family who were over on the
other side of the demilitarized zone but
at the same time this is somewhat
embarrassing to the Pentagon and it also
UPS the stakes in the particular region
in the last 24 hours the US's doctor
nuclear submarine of South Korea this is
something that North Korea has objected
to strongly describing it as an act of
War as an act of hostility so tensions
are very high in the region already
throw the fact that you've got a U.S
soldier wandering voluntarily it seems
across the border this is a very
difficult and tense situation indeed
yeah Mike thank you very much indeed
That's Mike Hannah talking to us from
Washington D.C